I really want to start with a really
sincere thank you for your work uh I
love your work I love how you Champion
IMAX and the large screen format I just
really want to thank you because I know
how hard it is to make movies well thank
you that's very kind of you to say I'm
so curious I saw pictures of the IMAX
platter and Oppenheimer and it seems
very close to the edge and I'm curious
if the actual run time of the film was
dictated At All by the platter of IMAX
well there's a relationship uh but no
the dictating went the other way and the
thing we've done with the platter over
the years because when I started working
with IMAX film it was okay two and a
half hours that's it and then we got to
Interstellar which went up to 247 and uh
what they were able to do for me is
engineer The Platters a little bit wider
so it has an extra rim and that got a
little wider and a little wider over the
years and then on this I went to them
and said okay I've got 180 page script
that it's a three hour movie on the nose
can it be done we looked at it they
looked at the platters and they came to
the conclusion that it could just be
done and they're telling me this is the
absolute limit because now the arm that
holds the plateau we're right up against
it so uh this this I think is finally
the the outer limit of running time for
an IMAX full print thank you for sharing
that story that's amazing
um so I'm fascinated by the editing
process because that's where movies come
together
um and I'm curious which of your films
changed the most in the editing room in
ways you didn't expect going in that's a
really hard one to answer because I'm a
writer director and so I do write
whether I co-write or I write by myself
that final draw for the script I very
much have an editing hat on already and
so structurally the films tend to be
um fairly disciplined I would say but
the discoveries you make in editing are
complex and multivaried and things
transform over time the the approach Jen
Lane my editor myself take is to view
the film as a whole and so we're
watching it every week we're putting it
up usually inviting one or two people in
who don't know anything about the script
to watch it with us see it through their
eyes
um and every film presents unique
challenges and I think in the case of
Oppenheimer it was very much
very much being Guided by the balance
between the color sequences where we're
trying to see everything from his point
of view be in his head see through his
eyes and then the black and white
sequences which are much more Robert
Downey Jr's point of view Lewis straws
is the character is playing
um I try to balance the subjective for
the objective and
give sufficient momentum to those two
timelines that they're gonna there's a
feeling of uh Confluence at the end but
every film's different every film has
its unique challenges uh and some films
are improved in the edit Suite through
tightening and speeding things up a lot
and that's very often our process other
films uh Interstellar as one where you
you couldn't just keep squeezing it it
wouldn't help the pacing you actually
needed to let things breathe let
um you know you needed to let the sights
and sounds you were experienced with the
audience breathe a bit hence the bigger
IMAX platter one of the things that I
can't believe you did was are there any
CGI shots in this movie there are no CGI
shots in the movie exactly yeah and I
just want to say first of all amazing
and second of all uh you the thing that
I was blown away by was you the way you
shot the explosions using IMAX cameras
because how how did you pull that off
well one of the first people I showed
the script to was my visual effects you
supervisor Andrew Jackson and I said to
him he's very well versed CG but he's
also very well very well versed in
Practical effects and understands the
value of that and I showed him very
early on and I said okay what we need in
this film is a thread between the
interior process of Oppenheimer he's
imagining he's visualizing of atoms
molecules those interactions those
energy waves
we need a thread that runs from that
right through to the ultimate expression
of the destructive power when that force
is Unleashed
it has to be it has to live in the same
family and I think computer graphics
the very versatile they can do all kinds
of things but they tend to feel a bit
safe that's why they're difficult to use
in horror movies uh animation tends to
feel a little safe for the audience the
Trinity test ultimately but also these
early imaginings of Oppenheimer
visualizing the quantum realm they had
to be threatening in some way they did
the bite of real world imagery the
Trinity test for those who were there
was the most beautiful and terrifying
thing simultaneously and that's where we
were headed with this film so he spent
many months working on extremely small
things and extremely large things in
combination with Scott Fisher or visual
uh special effects uh supervisor who is
second to none in the world of blowing
things up on a vast scale and so it was
really a combination of scales and
ultimately
that spoke to the whole of the film
because quantum physics and the
expression of quantum physics through uh
nuclear weapons is really about the
incredible disparity of scales you know
the laws of quantum physics work at this
you know tiny tiny level and then they
find expression out in the stars of
black holes and Supernova and all the
rest so we're really trying to embrace
both ends of the scale and uh Andrew's
methodology and how he achieved those
things truly did Embrace both of them
and that no need to stop I'm just going
to say sir your film is fantastic thank
you and I recommend to everyone watching
to see an iMac 70 millimeter thank you
very much thank you so much